well our political editor Beth Rigby is
here in the studio so Beth zahari and
Rob and essentially the Prime Minister
not being strong enough to stand up to
them there seems to be a theme that that
the opposition is returning to time and
time again that's exactly right Jane it
is the theme and storm are coming back
to this week upon week and in terms of
those six questions today you had two on
the zahawi tax Affairs you had two on
Rob and the bullying allegations and
then you had two on Boris Johnson and
some of the uh scandals and
controversies around him that are still
live and and what does this tell us it
tells us that labor think that this is
cutting through with the public and that
this is a fertile uh area if you like
um to harvest in terms of trying to
damage
um Rishi soon I kind of have to say I
was up in Darlington this week and I
went to a mum and babies group and you
know you've had babies I have babies
often you're not across the news when
you've got a newborn because you're busy
doing other things and all of the mums
that I spoke to knew about the zahawi
affair and had a strong view of it and
you know just in terms of true it has
cut through and and often Westminster
scandals don't but I think you know
talking to those moms it certainly had
and so I think there's difficulties for
Rishi soon out because it's having cut
through and it's undermining his
Integrity point about his government the
second thing I would say about it if you
drill down into it now George Osborne
the former Chancellor was saying at the
weekend that he thought the Prime
Minister was being dragged down by past
scandals under the Boris Johnson regime
but when you look at the issues around
Dominic Robb his Deputy Prime Minister a
key Ally for him in the leadership race
that was severely punished by Liz truss
when she became prime minister you know
Dominic Raab consigned to the back
benches and you know sent out to pasture
now he was on zahari he was on
originally next team exactly and Rob has
now been brought back and the questions
around these Eights separate complaints
of bullying these bullying allegations
which the Prime Minister has appointed
accused a
kc4 to investigate
is that the questions around whether
this comes to Rishi Sue next door and
one source was telling me uh this week
that the Prime Minister was made
directly aware of quote Rob's
unacceptable Behavior informally so yes
number 10 is saying oh he wasn't aware
of formal complaints when he appointed
him but is this going to stick or is the
issues around Rob going to come back and
tarnish and undermine Rishi sunap
because the defense he's been making
over zahari was I didn't know when I did
know I dealt with it and it might be
much harder for him to make those claims
about Dominic Rob and that now quite
unwieldy investigation with eight
separate complaints so you know George
Osborne saying that these are past
issues that are dragging him down the
question is is how close does it come to
his door and how personally damaging
could it become for him and I imagine in
number 10 that is now a real worry okay
Beth thanks very much